everybody yeah and if they say tours
peace what should you do so once I was a
listen to it again and if they two tours
peace
one second one second no a piece of cake
before know what is the peace
[Music]
so Angela
are you going - I'm gonna go today
Sura 8 is 6 feet okay God prepare
against them
yes whatever you can military to power
60 a warhorse this is what they're doing
here everyone right away the jihadist
push their luck killing whatever you can
military power war horses yeah they're
by the enemy of Allah yeah your enemies
and others besides him who we don't know
yeah but Allah knows them and whatever
you spend it Allah will be repaid in
full and you will not be wrong guys guys
guys you know what's funny wow the
following us
do not fight in some people guys oh when
you put sugar in see what happens
everything with his weights you finished
here this is what happens when you are
by the verse
yeah watch this now watch carefully
don't run off read carefully oh yeah
we're gonna see we're gonna see you
don't tell anyone ok prepare against
them whatever you can and oh I love you
know thy enemy
no they're coming to kiss me now
fighting a lot enemy and your own enemy
look allowances upon a lot less slaps
your face I an enemy and then the others
besides them whom you do not know Allah
knows them what everything you spend in
the way of our lives we paid you in food
and should not be wronged now chapter 61
listen carefully
is everybody ready and if they tilt
towards peace what should you do so once
I want listen listen again and if they
do towards peace what is the one second
one second no piece of cake before dawn
what is the peace any relationship let
me finish and if they talk to towards
peace you too should choose towards it
[Music]